bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaykum
peace be unto you welcome to another
episode of Deen show to bring you up to
speed quickly we have been doing a
series with our good friend Sheikh use
of esters we've been talking about the
prophets prophets and messengers who the
most merciful the most loving one the
creator of the heavens and earth he has
sent throughout time to guide the human
beings so you go under the Deen show
calm use of Estes and you click on his
special section and you will catch up
and come up to speed with all the other
shows that we cover we covered Adam Noah
Moses Abraham and today and Jesus peace
be upon all of them and we're going to
be talking today wrapping it up with the
last and final mission of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
without further delay let's bring out
former Christian minister preacher
Sheikh Yusuf Estes we'll be right back
assalamualaikum Alex I said I never said
that how are you Sheikh Hamdan
hamdullah you're gonna be running for
president soon maybe I'll be running
from the president
but I was listening as you were
introducing the program just before it
came out and you were mentioning about
the what we'd covered in the past and I
feel like we've really done a disservice
to our audience if we tell them that we
really covered it because we didn't
cover in depth on anything not really
yeah there is so much to say and I hope
that they'll get a chance to review some
of the previous programs but also
they'll go to our website it's called
ww-watch Islam com there's a section
there for the Kasasa lobbyists stories
of the prophets it was done in India for
the children we had a big children's
project over there to help them to
better understand we wanted the children
of India to know more about the prophets
and then we televised it and then make
program copies and there are free
anybody can go there ww-watch Islam
there's a menu on the left of the page
it drops down go to the bottom which
said list all bottom of that page and
you can see I think 16 episodes out of
the 52 episodes we did now when we talk
about these prophets one of the things
that I've been trying to stress in our
few episodes that we've done here is
that it's not so much important to know
the chronological order to know
particular it's not going to be like a
history test but it needs to be that
we understand who are these guys yes are
they really prophets because there are
some who have claimed to be prophets who
aren't and there are people who said the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him is
not the prophet that he claimed to be
and then there are others that say yeah
they believe he's a prophet but they
also accept some other people who will
will say that weren't for instance there
was one in more recent decades by the
name of Rashid Khalifa claimed to be a
prophet in Arizona who was he now
Russia Khalifa what religion was he
preaching or economy he was a Muslim
okay
Russian Khalifa claim to be a prophet he
established something that group today
called submitters International we will
disagree with that that he was a prophet
because we will say that that Muhammad
is the last and final messenger and
prophet the last of the UM BIA and the
last of the results this was a holster I
think that's too far go that extent
because I don't know what delusion he
may have had and and but as far as the
criterion and this is for us yeah we
measure everything up with a benchmark a
criterion and and without being too hard
on anybody but another one would be
golem Achmed about a hundred years ago
from Cuddy on India I'm Arthur Harmon
Elijah Muhammad definitely he was in
about 1930 1931 he also claimed to be a
prophet Joseph Smith Joseph Smith
claimed to be a prophet about 150 years
ago coming from New England and going
around to I think about Indiana is where
he was killed and then they considered
him to be a prophet but we'll we'll use
a benchmark or criterion and say that if
somebody is going to be a prophet these
are the things that they would have to
measure tell us what is that well first
of all there they have to claim to be
one okay so and this that we talked
about all did claim that another would
be that their character would be
impeccable they would have an excellent
character no they could be given to
making mistakes along the way you know
anybody could make a mistake we
mentioned Moses killed somebody hit the
man with one hit and better killed him
might have broke his neck I don't know
but he unintentionally he in
hitting yeah but he obviously didn't
mean to kill him
yeah and then there was the case of
Abraham lying to the people about being
a brother to his wife when actually it's
not his sister's his wife and again he
we could use rationalization well we're
all brothers and sisters in humanity and
they were brothers and sisters in faith
or something like that but this would be
a mistake but not out of character of a
prophet because they can make those kind
of mistakes as our after all human they
have to eat drink go to the bathroom
sleep those are all characteristics of
prophets because they're humans and you
have to be a human to be a prophet so if
somebody came to you and said well this
guy doesn't eat he doesn't sleep and and
he floats in the air and all these kinds
of things well that's probably a genie
yeah a jinn but it is not a real prophet
because he has to be from us has to
relate to us in our own not only our own
language but also in our own culture in
our own traditions that we can see what
he's saying is good and what's bad and
we can take his word for it
believe him how could someone do
intelligent analysis to see that because
I've heard some people try to put the
prophet the last and final motion of
Prophet Muhammad in the same category as
someone like Joseph Smith or some of
these imposters that came along well
well let and I'll let the viewer do that
for themselves and tell you that in
order to be from Almighty God they do
need to have some kind of identification
like a badge and it's a good idea a good
badge and the badge or identification of
a prophet
especially when it's a Rasul we talked
about special prophets that but a cut
above their average prophet
these are the ones that come with an
actual message canceling anything that
it might have been corrupted prior to
that for instance 10 commandments are
clear but there were a lot of other
Commandments that came along to that if
you look at you may question why maybe
it was indicative at the time that they
were there receiving it maybe it's
something that they came up with
themselves and added to it but for you
and I for
since we have no problem working on
Saturdays whereas the Jewish faith they
don't allow that for the Christians they
don't they're not supposed to do any
work on Sunday well we don't have a
problem that is Friday is our day and we
were able to work and play and do what
we want on Friday except for that one
hour or so there were supposed to be
sitting there listening to the Juma
Salah
that we have an obligation for and so
this is how things might become updated
if you will if you don't mind to use
that but with each of the real prophets
that came their signs were clear and
they were observed by trustworthy people
or community communicated it to their
people and they should be known to you
who they are and where it comes from now
today we can easily verify Jesus we can
easily verify Solomon and David and
Moses and Abraham and Adam clearly and
without any doubt in our minds as
Muslims because they're mentioned in the
Quran mm-hmm but if somebody wants to
come up with something other than that
they would have to have a proof stronger
than the Quran so our benchmark is going
to be the Quran itself for us the Quran
is the final word not just the final
word as in a conversation that's my word
that's my final word but also it's the
final word of Allah he's not going to
send any more and he said so Allah has
made it clear he is not going to send it
anything else and he doesn't need you
because we have it why do you need
another revelation when you got the
Quran right now what's the matter you
don't take time to learn Arabic that's
your problem but it's clear and it's
there
Quran is there hmm and it hasn't changed
now there are those who have tried and
tried to insist that it's been changed
this and that they made websites but
anybody who has done even a cursory that
study of the subject has to come to
conclusion that now they're wrong and
they're things that they are trying to
suggest they haven't researched it
themselves they just to go from some
and when somebody's a real scholar come
and say no you look reading in Arabic
and you can see so the Quran is very
much verifying Jesus Christ peace be
upon him as the Messiah he is the Christ
he is the one who was to come and lead
the Jews but what the Jews of the time
didn't understand the children of Israel
didn't understand that he would be here
twice he came he left and he will be
back this is known to us as Muslims
clearly the Jesus peace be upon him yes
he was here and did walk with the people
he taught a message and then he was
pulled up to God at least with Allah and
to be back in the last day
we're the only other religion to believe
the Christians believe that and we
believe that
who else can make such a claim I don't
going off on a tangent who don't the
Jews they're expecting a messiah even to
this day they're still expecting when
Jesus returns some of the Jews will
recognize him as the Messiah and they'll
accept it some Christians were
recognizing some Muslims different
people will recognize him now they
talked about this Messiah coming that
you know there'll be peace that the lamb
will lay down with the that will happen
but this is the same thing that we have
so that's the Messiah what we're talking
about will happen Jesus peace hasn't
happened yet because it will it will
come at a time of war yeah and when it
comes down there will be one here called
the Antichrist or the macidull
yeah that's an Arabic Missa Hey from
Messiah did y'all false messiah the liar
now you'll see a lot of crookedness what
I mean is ambiguity in a lot of the
previous scriptures because we know we
don't have the originals but everything
if you study it starts to make sense
because you see consistency of the same
message and insistency of the message
where it is consistent is this is
important because i've measured that up
to the Quran and I found there's no
contradiction between Quran and Bible
except where the Bible is contradicting
itself and in those places it does
contradict itself against the Quran but
the Quran has no inconsistency no
contradiction in it and those who try to
promote that in say
yes there is it's this it's that and all
you bring them and sit with them and
talk with them and you'll find they will
run away as soon as you start to show
what about this what about that do you
know the Arabic language did you read it
in Arabic do you know what it is said
about that and they will try to come
with weak or fabricated hadith and claim
all this stuff but the Quran is never
ever ever been successfully challenged
by anyone tell us because this is the
last show on this series and we're
talking about the last and final message
of the Prophet Muhammad can you talk
about when the revelation came how this
actually happened he was in the mountain
and he was meditating can you talk about
this well first of all it is important
to have I think a complete program for
that yeah and we don't have time there
in this series so let us just state
general I'm just on the prophets
themselves without getting too deep but
the same angel that came to Mary and
told her she was going to have a baby is
Gabriel and he's called Gabriel in
Arabic Jabril came to Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him just as he came to
other prophets in the past yes yes and
ordered him to recite and when he said a
lot of people in English they say read
this wrong bad translation it's not bad
it's incorrect and correct
so it's recited because it could be read
but it doesn't carry the proper
connotation because it would mean that
the Gabriel didn't know what he was
supposed to be doing mm-hmm because
father Muhammad was illiterate in owner
not a rewrite okay so why would he be
ordering that he was ordering him a
chorale recite because finally it comes
what shall I recite yes it tells him I'd
recite actually and what he tells him to
recite it Cora bismi rabbika alladhi
khalaq harmful in sentiment a laka it
grow well rebuke electron Allah the
Alamo bill Kalam
well Alma was in Santa mallamma ha I'll
forgive me for any mistake but the
translation more or less is saying that
recite in the name of your Lord so
that's why when we recite we say
bismillah monarchy recite in the name of
your Lord who created all human beings
from a nilachal reciting your Lord is so
generous and he taught human beings how
to use a pen it's his man taught man how
to use a pen taught them what they
didn't know we said in one of our first
programs we talked about each Reese
Enoch he's the one who this is talking
about that Allah taught him he was the
first of the people to learn to read and
write how'd you talk there because I've
heard an argument someone said that he
was choked again going back to not
knowing the Arabic have a Mohammed yeah
I had a conversation I saw that on the
Internet you saw that what a joke
now just we don't want to go too deeply
into this but this is obviously
incorrect he wasn't well first of all I
said we would have criterion that we
would use yeah well I will just say
prove what you said yeah that's the
criterion when you have verified human
beings by name and we know when they
were born we know when and where they
died we know people that knew them will
also verify them so it's a network not
some random person did you just make up
a name and say this is John and Fred and
George yeah yeah you know who's Fred who
George who we didn't know who these
people aren't we know very well who they
are so what are they saying in the
arabic they say that the message came to
him and he was there in the cave in the
mountain of light he was fasting his
fasting okay and what happens the angel
enters upon him and says to him recite
and he says i'm not a reciter recite and
each time he does squeeze him squeezing
but it is said that the the enthusiasm
of the angel who had been waiting since
the creation of adam for this chance to
finally get to see him it was very
excited it's like I was excited oh I
can't compare to that but kind of I got
excited to see you so I give you a nice
low yeah you did you and you almost
squeezed me you know they're the same
kind of grasp that you gave me hugging
me when we first started this show some
time back you hugged me yeah and
it was even that extra little excitement
so I squeeze you like that so that kind
of squeeze we guys in martial arts need
to be careful you know but for sure this
is I think a chance for people to
realize when somebody wants to
disbelieve they will make up they will
lie they will repeat other lies and they
will take something from somebody who's
even a known liar rather than to
consider this because they don't really
want to believe it alone yeah so anyway
setting that aside what makes a person a
false prophet well there is no criteria
to back him up what is the criterion to
back up for instance Ghulam Ahmed there
were many people that knew him and heard
him contradict himself we know that
there were people hundred years ago who
know and heard and even the British
newspaper which written controlled India
at the time wrote him up because he and
one of the last things he declared I
think it was in September 1907 or
something like that he declared that he
was God those his last statement because
they found him dead in his own toilet he
had what they call amoebic dysentery or
something similar to it and he actually
fell into doors were open Twilight's by
the way and he fell into it in drowned I
mean this is and this is known how about
this Joseph Smith character I want to
say character like that because I have
respect for the Mormon people themselves
and I don't wish to hurt their feelings
yeah I'm sorry but historically we do
know that he was killed and there were
different reports some said that he was
shot and others said that he was hung
and then there was one that even said
that he was split open in his innards
taken out which is very horrible but in
any case he was murdered yes and I was
putting that aside because prophets have
been murdered mm-hmm so that man even
caused me to say well let's look a
little bit closer but we also know that
he had business deals and he issued his
own coinage or money from those business
deals even in Ohio they still have
records of his actual signature
on those bills that he signed out from
his funding companies that he put
together and whatever happened to those
companies I'm not blaming him or saying
he was you know but profits don't get
into those kind of deals and if you look
deeper have you looked it kind of gets
weird that Jesus was the brother of
Lucifer and that all the human beings
are gonna be gods they're my god
semi gods if they if in order for the
real prophet just weird watchings
if he comes if he's got to be coming
with the same message of that yes so
this is nothing that the previous
prophets taught if it is show it to us
yeah okay so no proof so getting back
out in one go
another thing is the proof itself if you
said well we have a proof okay where is
it well they said it was gold tablets of
a Down and in the ocean nobody knows
where they are
okay then you don't have it anymore okay
but we have the living miracle the crime
in the beginning of the Book of Mormon
it says this is the one that I have at
home he said this is the 19
such-and-such version replacing all the
previous versions in correcting all the
mistakes that statement alone is replug
right here yeah because the next one
came out said the same thing about that
way and the what does the verbatim word
of God say this is a book where is no
doubt that says deep state actually it
didn't say it exactly a cure center it
says it like this it doesn't say how the
it's a Dalek yes
Dalek okay table Lara yes see he who did
a more talking this is a book it's not
the way to say it because that would be
hada yes it says Dalek uh-huh that is
the book that is the book that book with
a law whose the book wherein there is no
doubt yes yes source of guidance for
those who are god-fearing now we're
talking about the Quran this is the very
first word chapter 2 so it's not saying
this our little key tableau right but he
who did a little more
King this is what it says that is the
book wherein there is no doubt a source
of guidance for those who are having
fear of their Lord now it's important to
look at something here that when you say
that this is not the one in your hand
that's right it is the recitation that
you're hearing so Quran means recitation
or on literally means recitation
what's recited so what you just heard
was Quran yes and when how does it you
can't see it you can see me but you
can't see that it is exciting talk about
talking about because there's no
confusion no crookedness here not what
you just said when you open up this book
of Mormons that this is a replacing well
it's not I don't need to attack anybody
not to attack but just to see when you
see the truth coming how it just clear
it straight no ambiguity hope is witness
they also have their own translation of
the Bible and their own beliefs what I
say is that when you start going after
this to pinpoint one or the other these
so-called prophets you will alienate
yourself in front of these other people
for no reason there's no benefit why
don't we just talk about what we have
okay and let the people come to their
own conclusion tell us before there's a
couple more points before we come to an
end another argument that I've heard is
that when the Prophet peace be upon a
last fundamental problem Ahamed when he
had this revelation he didn't know if it
was from who it was from he ran back
scared to his wife how do you refute
this you've heard this argument well
actually he said it himself so let's
let's take what he said he said that he
has this experience that the angel
Gabriel came to him and repeated it
three times to him to recite and told
him what to recite and then when he he
was upset of course because I mean now
how would you feel if you were in a cave
in a mountain in the night time because
that would happen in a night time and
somebody comes in there and you know
startled you and starts talking you in
your language in a beautiful way and
then they just like disappear well what
would you think so when he came back he
was thinking about
he sat down he told his wife cover me up
cover me up and she's saying what's
going on he said just cover me up so he
was cold this could be from the night or
it could be shuttering from the
experience she robbed him up and then
after a while he was talking to her like
a man talks to his wife he very openly
and say what's in your mind and he said
I'm wondering if I'm nuts because look
this is what happened to me what do you
say I think any normal person would
think he's nuts well I don't know what
normally is because there's no other way
to exist I need experience
that has been a unique experience and so
she is listening to what he's saying yes
and she tells him that no I don't think
that there's in that you're nuts or
anything because I know you'd be all for
15 years that they were married at that
time they've been married 15 years she
said she never heard him tell a lie
this many 15 years Wow in a in a place
in those days that lion was common he
never told a lie and she said and he was
good to bring the families together he
was also known as the trustworthy he was
also known as the advocate the champion
of the downtrodden and that kind of
thing very generous and kind and so why
would God send some kind of mixed up
thoughts to him and she said I believe
your message which was to know that
there's only one God so this is
mentioned yes she says I believe there
is only one God and we should worship
Him and not these statues because Arabia
was filled up with these false notions
superstitions and incorrect worship at
that time so she said and confirmed that
yes I believe there's only one God and
you're his messenger and by her doing so
she becomes the very first Muslim and
this argument that someone might bring
up is just very weak if you look at it
the way you just explained it very
eloquently I mean any rational person
you start mentioning like being choked
another one is to say had epileptic
seizures I'll have received this week's
Newsweek and it was reminded of an
article that I read sometime back about
epilepsy and epilepsy it you read there
though all of the signs of epilepsy or
nothing that was ever described about
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him yeah
this was just something attached to it
but talk to people that have it one in
10 people in the United States have
epilepsy so it's not gonna be that hard
for you to find somebody and ask them
you know you noticed did this happen did
that happen and know that this is not
what happened to her not whatsoever
let's start to conclude and sum up we
started with the first man and prophet
Adam we talked about Moses Abraham no I
know pretty much some of the main
messages and prophets we came to the
conclusion now with the last and final
messenger sent the man that kind of
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him what
do we want the people to leave after
watching this whole series give us some
advice show what were the purpose behind
us sharing all of this is to identify
what makes somebody a prophet at the
same time we should identify what it's
not a prophet and also that not to
consider ourselves as prophets the last
and the final message itself is the
Quran if you're in doubt about it bring
a book like it that's the challenge
number one bring 10 surahs or chapters
like it challenge number 2 bring even
one chapter like it that's challenge
number three another one is do not the
disbelievers observe that if it were
from other than Allah they would find in
it many contradictions and then another
challenge it says we shall show them our
science on the far the Sun rising and
within themselves and this is mentioned
in Quran Allah saying we is the Royal we
not that there's any plural with God we
know so look at these challenges we'll
do it and look to the signs now I would
like to take this opportunity to mention
another website this one is called
science Islam dot-com there are nine
videotapes of nine scientists not Muslim
who went to I believe it was done in UAE
or I'm not real sure where they did this
I'd have to go back and look yes but
this conference was held maybe 15 years
so you got all their testimonies its
videos they're on which works on camera
its science is the science Islam being
one of them actually accepted Islam
while they were videotaping there's
somebody out there right now that
probably wants to accept the way of life
of all these messengers what you said
earlier when you define please do it
again the five things that equal to one
word Islam is from the word as Lama as
Lama in English has no single word you
need five words surrender submission and
obedience in sincerity and in being in
peace with whatever your environment or
circumstance is after you've done the
other four that person wants to accept
this way of life what do they have to do
first thing they need to do is to open
up their own hearts clean out at all the
misconceptions clean out false notions
any hatred any bigotry that they have
they need to remove it because the law
is not going to guide them then when
when they've done that and said I and
how you do this keep saying I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm wrong I'm wrong I'm wrong
in your head humble yourself yeah
very humble and in that condition say oh
my lord oh god or whatever you calling
not Jesus not Mohammed not Moses but God
guide me and be honest and sincere and
look and watch what comes to you the
guidance that you get after that is the
guidance you should follow this is deep
and very simple no crookedness in it is
the straight path thank you very much
for being with us just one more time
that website with those scientists
testimony science Islam confines Islam
calm and the the videos are there thank
you for helping us with this series we
hope to have you again back here again
sometime soon on the Dean show inshallah
and thank you for being with us you've
seen that consistent message has been
the same it wasn't a new way of life
sent with every messenger it's been that
way that way of submitting
to the one god simple as that submit
yourself to the one God do with the
shake advise us to do to humble
ourselves and repent to God alone just
like Adam did Abraham and all the
messengers and humbly ask God to guide
you and be ready for comes next and we
hope to see you again next time here on
the Deen show until then assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you